What is the most valuable agentic
automation work?
I think scientific research
is quite high on that list.
After a decade working in life sciences
collaboration projects,
I think that more tools alone will not
enable automation of scientific
research.
Because science work relies on
collaboration.
For agents to collaborate autonomously,
we need a chain of verifiable receipts.
We need a solution which can provide
these receipts proving every step,
ensuring that every result can be
trusted, and enabling collaboration at
scale.
Let's step back.
Imagine an
Imagine agents as cooks in the kitchen.
Giving them more tools improves
kitchen's efficiency.
Better knives, more pans, more ovens
boost the speed and quality.
But it only enhances local work.
Scientific work
is
not cooking alone in your own kitchen.
It is closer to running a Michelin star
restaurant.
The outcomes depend on suppliers and
their produce,
the level of service that you can
provide,
and an ability to consistently deliver
the same quality dish again and again
and again.
You can cannot bring everything into one
kitchen.
The challenge isn't local tools.
It is aligning the entire supply chain.
Today we already have plenty of tools
for
agents and agent automation.
On other hand, we also have data and
specialized analytics algorithms,
which are distributed across
organizations and and and live in silos.
At Alifeia, our vision for Froglet
is very simple.
As agentic workflow automation matures,
organizations will
not just give agents more tools,
they will allocate them budgets.
We already kind of doing it in a
primitive way,
allocating them token budgets
per task.
The next step is a bit broader.
It's allowing agents to manage their own
budget
for
anything that they might need,
discovering services, requesting data,
negotiating execution,
paying for work
in cross-organizational
boundary setting.
At that point, the agent is no longer
just a cook with a better knife.
It starts acting like an executive chef,
finding suppliers,
ordering ingredients,
coordinating kitchen
the kitchen work,
and keeping a record of everything
what's happening.
That is why we're building Froglet.
The protocol for a agents to discover,
transact with, and receive verifiable
receipts
for external data and services
and service providers.
Froglet is designed to sit in between of
many moving parts.
And that's why we are not replacing
existing tools and protocols.
We integrate with different payment
rails,
with different agent and harnesses,
execution environments, and even
network transport protocols.
It does not require that everyone has
the same software stack.
It just requires that everyone has the
same interface.
For more details, please visit
froglet.dev.
Where you will be able to run to see how
to run Froglet locally with just one
command.
Or you can even try Froglet remotely
with just one prompt.
So, in essence,
close scientific collaboration often
turns into a bespoke enterprise project.
That can take years and cost millions
before even first reusable
workflow exists.
On the other hand, the Froglet's mission
is to simplify that much more.
Once your organization has deemed that
the resource is shareable,
a provider should be able
to
expose it for Froglet.
An agent can discover it,
understand its terms, request the work,
and receive verifiable receipt.
That costs few thousand tokens and takes
minutes.
Let's deep dive a bit deeper.
So, here is our Froglet Dev website, and
here you can see
um
a walkthrough button. If you click on
it, you will have a much more detailed
review of what's happening, and you can
read documentation in even more detail.
So, first of all, the Froglet network
consists of homogeneous nodes.
Every single actor in the environment
runs the same core
um
node.
It just plays a different role. There
are requesters, there are providers,
and there is a marketplace, which is a
just a Froglet running the specialized
service.
What it solves is how to find
how for a requester to find the
providers,
how to trust them, how to battle pay or
settle,
and how to prove that execution has
happened.
Whenever you're generating a new node,
you're generating a key pair for
identity and signing.
And every time you execute anything with
Froglet, it uses your keys to sign
on the chain. And the chain consists of
everything what you do, from descriptors
to offer to quote to deal for invoice
and finally receipt.
Therefore, you cannot tamper with any
part of this chain.
Otherwise, the chain will be broken.
And to discover services, providers of
services, just register and describe
their services to the marketplace.
Marketplace itself provides the services
for providing descriptions
and for indexing what's
what is existing what services existing
on the marketplace.
Once a requester requests an index of
available services,
from there on, it continues direct
communication with that requester.
It doesn't need a middleman.
So, the requester and provider
communicates
with each other directly, and it all
happens in one interaction: requests,
signing, execution, and receipt.
On a payment side, we have a system
where it where all payments, if it's not
free, has two parts. One is a base
payment, and another is success fee.
So, base payment protects the providers
that they wouldn't be attacked by uh
multiple requests.
And success fee is providing the
requesters from malicious providers.
In essence,
the Froglet [snorts] itself is not an AI
agent, but it is created specifically
for agents
as an interface to find each other.
As an interface to find the data and
services cross borders
and execute these deals directly
with each other.
So, coming back to recap,
a froglet lets agent to discover
external scientific resources,
execute work across organizational
boundaries,
and it gives every transaction a
verifiable receipt.
Together, this opens the door to
autonomous scientific progress.
We hope you will join us and enjoyed
this talk.
Thank you.